Spencer Hawes ds3 bound to brown go
chunks
[Applause]
here comes junior Smith where's Jenna
Pitman's take advantage of James will
never be the same
Andina salutes it's at least a funny
[Applause]
turn
Bob he said it
he is underappreciated underrated indeed
mental ears nine one one nine one who he
said he realized he was gonna have to
step up in this game I guess he's been
doing that so far what is LeBron James
have just bailed out the Cavaliers with
that and we call in a block shop yeah
Marv it was so loud in here it looked
like it was a goat in the bids got upset
I don't even know if the referees have
cleared it up with themselves
James clubbing last touched by Americans
will not get that call great defense
right there by James with a great pump
fake right here my Marion said she
didn't know LeBron was coming good look
he gets up
[Applause]
let's get to him before he gets the ball
here's my poster all the chased out of
James
one of the fastest players whooping for
than a at this stage of his career in
the NBA penis the ball telefono bottom
again
did he seriously do that
mark Davis's hang on got to be careful
here ball what happened but LeBron
knocks it away games the back stolen by
Ginobili
sniffing pursue table clock by James
a 20-second timeout call by Cleveland
LeBron James doing a little bit of
everything
knocked away by Bazemore he forces back
on the Hawks T going downhill get that
weak stuff out here trying to get down
inside the brown reason and says no no
I'm not in his house tonight
Irving tribes will defend this ball
knocked away by Barnes
Iguodala ahead to curry Shumpert in
pursuit blocked by James rejects it out
of bounds
good hustle defensively
pull-up jumper two pointer not that time
deflected taken by Iguodala off to the
races ride past urban gets inside layup
blocked by James back out to Clary open
three couple it could look some prey for
Golden State will not Paul
[Applause]
points 15 rebounds
it's pendulum here in Cleveland Mary
blocked by James
[Applause]
making a statement on both sides of the
floor Terry tries again left-handed
blocked by James rejected out of bounds
he's done that a couple of times in
these finals and the two of them have
some words Shumpert getting involved
[Applause]
Irving drives hop step in size flows up
misses rebound taken by Iguodala
they go down with a curry back there get
down up for the lamp Oh blocked by James
LeBron James with the rejection Wow
this third block of the game as we come
up on a minute the half remaining they
said it's picked off by Bradley James
back
[Applause]
it worked out pretty well Dave Jones cut
off by Chris Cody and it's stolen by
bloodstone chased by Irving Millsap got
away with a push on Tristan Thompson and
James with an emphatic block on
Sefolosha Sefolosha like he took a hit
to the head from Shumpert LeBron James
is all over the floors
what else can he do
[Music]
[Applause]
his satellite my speed mental abroad it
is his fourth rejection of I want the
switch of t gun LeBron the way you gotta
get this and they turn over James and a
chase-down block he erased it now you
can see that he is young was looking for
where the defense is and he slowed down
and that gives LeBron that time now just
keep an eye on them I watch it said will
turn
[Applause]
face down the gutter let me handle
German radishes Chuck came up with it
not even the perfect spots it does it
was Magoo
Lillard bloque lejos the play
I mean Damien was true well that went
down he's thinking barn right at the
free-throw line local side of the lake
it looks different from last year oh
those up high sends it back on Stauskas
once this season in the preseason
here's we got
[Applause]
Irving pulls it back top Rose finds the
open man hello Derrick Rose makes the
Hall of Fame every former MVP that's
eligible no you can leave
that's a four-time MVP right there
making a statement he's amazing
offensive foul on
taking my mother on one he goes right at
JD's son steps blocked by James since
say so recovery LeBron James brings it
the other way
[Applause]
great lunch nice that would have cut it
to seven all of a sudden gotta stop the
ball on the feed
[Applause]
get that witch stuff out of his what was
missed off for you know that's not like
him comes baseball since the passion
sidewalk
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what does the chemo he's do new Prince
he puts him his place oh my goodness
[Music]
put an exclamation point from the king
can you believe it now that was a time
rock they're just like the rocking lead
in the championship game that's what he
can really do gets all the way never be
the same
well the Brian James baby them in on
that one he just waited for him and
waited for me
[ __ ] deadly stuff
[Music]
Joe saw he had a free lane in the bucket
women and older people and it has abroad
he came together
champion switch jetty Austin against
Jimmy Butler attacking that boom never
been the same one second left in
overtime
my goodness good deadly stuff on it
you think LeBron was ready for that
shots came out of nowhere this is pain
trying to get off the shop
it's tough going
SiC that he took his defender to advance
it watch he takes an angle least
traveled and
[Applause]
but the Nile
James
[Applause]
possession with three seconds to go
blown away picked up by brown vines
Rosia proof behind and lamp blocked by
James what a sensational block Rozier
made such a great catch the ball was
behind him and nearly made a sensational
fly's of the series Mars throws an end
Baines goes inside blocked by James
right at the rim they are Smith inside
the arc Hill hustling after Paul knocked
out of bounds last touched by Morris
good hustle
Rozier blocked by Green excuse me James
falling behind and rejection out of
bounds the chase-down block stolen by
Rozier three on one break for Boston
Rose here to the basket blocked by James
he did it again
three drives misses and a rebound
against Boston with 320 remaining here
in the third the momentum has changed
well full disclosure though my he did it
again to turn over a picked up by
Williams here comes Hammond child
knocked it away retrieve I booked us
into Harold apply to the James Davis
child James's trailer
[Applause]
take this with 13 seconds Danny Green
for three
rebound blinkers seven not doing by
Liles first thought that was goaltending
fire
makers get that that ciders goes quickly
chased out
he's trained
that's LeBron James group Andre is
really a nice recovery because he was
who had given up the middle but he
recovers and just keeps his eye on it
Taizo lay it up softly on by the end
zone there comes
[Applause]
bullying you can't get hit the other end
Phillip leaving it and it's going to be
out of bounds what if you guys would
play